the thing I love about animation is that
we get to create a world that no one has
seen before
what John Lasseter always encourages us
to do is make the world feel believable
let the audience believe this could
actually exist CPD's first rabbit
officer Judy Hopps we did a lot of
research into the animal world in this
film in doing that research there was an
interesting fact that kind of popped up
the prey make up 90% of the population
and predators make up 10% we went to
Kenya one of the things we noticed in
Africa we were about 30 feet from a
watering hole where during the day Lions
would come in to drink right next to the
zebras which they normally eat right
that's very much like human society
where different groups don't always get
along but they have to find a way to
coexist that's how the movie started to
develop into this idea
bad news in this city gripped by fear we
keep pushing our tech department to
solve challenges with every movie this
one had tons of them how to depict fur
begin a very realistic way two years ago
we could not have made this movie the
way we did today that level of movement
on each of the characters makes the
world feel alive to see the individual
strands for just having a little bit of
movement on it and gets one of the
fantastic things especially in the IMAX
over and over again people have comment
on how detailed and immersive the world
is it really feels like a real city it's
it's vast and what we love about IMAX is
that you guys celebrate everything that
is great about film you show it the way
it should be shown the way we always
hope it will be shown and in some ways
that makes it more fantastic in terms of
what we're creating and what the
audience gets to discover
we may be loved but deep down we're
still animal you want this world to wash
over you you want to be surrounded by
the sound and feel every moment it's
just immense it's that level of detail
and the craftsmanship that went into it
really can be explored and just seen in
its greatness on such a fantastic venue
as IMAX in IMAX we can see every one of
those details IMAX is the way to see it